tonight on Kitchen
Nightmares Mojito's Cuban Cafe feels
like the set of a soap opera that stars
two hot Latin lovers they were once
romantic newly WTS everybody said you
are the perfect couple proud owners of a
restaurant they treated like a newborn
baby it's everything for me today the
passion is gone the marriage is over and
the business is on the Rocks get
together Marcelo control listen I try to
control everything she used to show
respect for me no now do it do it do it
do it now the person that I was married
to he's gone always at each other's
throats I want to kill her the staff is
constantly caught in the crossfire who's
trying to sabotage this that's all we
here every day there's problems between
then too Catalina Marcelo is constantly
fighting let me talk is definitely
hurting the restaurant to save Mojitos
Chef Ramsey must find out what killed
the marriage did she meet another man
yeah do you love him or these two
soulmates will see the death of their
dream I'm not doing a right because it's
not perfect follow my kitchen tonight
the soap opera of Mojitos do you think
it's time that one of you says goodbye
marel should quit but I'll go to the
endend
[Music]
Brooklyn New York just across the East
River from Manhattan this historic
neighborhood has become a hip and trendy
place to live 7 years ago Kata and
Marcelo moved here just after they got
married we always wanted to have a
restaurant and wanted to make a drink
I'm true we decide to open a restaurant
Mojitos a Cuban
food we live together upstairs in the
apartment hi guys how are you welcome um
marel and I we both come out with
different specials all the time I've
been cooking my whole life and I love it
we share responsibilities of the
restaurant he takes the back house and I
take the front house I do the food the
orders the payroll I do everything but a
year after we opened the restaurant
things started going very
bad Marcelo and I are constantly
fighting just have the rice have the
rice you're right there yes we I on it
Marcelo why don't you listen to me no
let me feel in my way in my way she have
the book how Dy Marcelo crazy first say
you don't do nothing isn't that your
responsibility second clap do it do it
do it now okay chees a that's not the
way you make it I don't respect Marcelo
because he doesn't know how to handle
pressure where the woman cheese here the
cheer you don't know they will fight in
front of customers pick up the food on
time it gets
ugly because of the fighting we
separated 2 years ago I get another
apartment in Queens and I and I I live
there we destroy our marriage and I
don't want to destroy my restaurant
there's no money in the bank zero we
have invested everything we have like
$300,000 if I lost a restaurant I will
lost my dream I'll lost my baby this is
my baby I sacrifice for Mojito's my
relationship
where is Kata the most important thing I
have Mojitos destroy our
[Music]
lives
sorry mojito is the restaurant about to
visit what I do know is it's the only
Cuban restaurant in Brooklyn so that has
to be a big plus but what I don't know
is why do they need my help right
well hello hi
hi hello first name is Catalina Catalina
nice to meet you nice meeting you and
you're the I'm one of the owners SL Chef
okay I have a partner Marcelo it's his
name right we used to be married we've
been separated for 2 years you used to
be married to my partner oh Jesus this
is like water and oil we just don't mix
anymore it's just like conflict all the
time well it's all about the uh food
I'll have a look through the menu nice
to meet you same here okay enjoy your
lunch thank
you oh my god a real interesting Decor
yeah it's almost like a sort of garage
sale that gone
wrong how are you sir good how are you
yeah round D thank you and let's start
off with chicken classic soup let's go
for the pascar Marinaro the yeah
absolutely I really believe chff rans
going to going to like the food I think
the 97 % of my food will be
great thank you very much that was very
fast very fast indeed let's hope it's
[Music]
good it's
cold I don't want be a pain in the ass I
can I have a soup hot it's cold hot it's
cold W let me get that hot for you okay
absolutely uh he would like a hot soup
not cold who said that uh Ramsey
said
[Music]
what happened with the soup I have a
thermometer here boiling hat you want to
check you want to check with me it
wasn't boiling hat now you see it's
boiling hat now it is but when it went
out it was before you you guys send
something up please check double check
triple check check one more time yes yes
listen go to your
bar
I'm sorry about that don't worry just
want I went to taste these These are so
salty I mean you'd need six Mojitos
before you start eating in six spoons of
that right they're disgusting excuse me
let me take this back what a shame I
can't even get the basics right do me a
favor try the means Marcelo try the
[Music]
means salty as hell throw it out
get it together Marcelo control listen I
try to control everything I try to
control everything I'm going I going to
tast for throw them out exchange them
for new ones listen let me pi the the CH
let me pi the CH okay F let me
the
here my God there's definitely
definitely a lack of Harmony in the
kitchen it's going getting C instead of
arguing do it do it do it do it now I
want this one right like
now oh my God that's going to be a
complete disaster change your things and
do what you have to do go out here I'm
not going out go out here go out out my
kitchen go out of my kitchen go out of
my kitchen
now how you doing yeah fine thank you
and you I'm fine can I get you anything
else while you wait now I'm going to
wait for the clap here okay thank you I
hope it comes all right thank you very
much all right wow I know I can't
believe it the beans the basic of
us I hope you enjoy it cuz it's actually
my favorite dish thank
[Music]
you
delicious
wow he love it yeah he loves
it fish is not cooked the fish is not
cooked ah it's really
not that is a shame I'm going to bring
it back that's a very big mistake stick
on behalf of the
kitchen not
cooked raw fish what's wrong with you
guys it's raw it's not cook I put the
Tester the the OV test this is raw raw
raw ra ra this never comes wrong what's
wrong hey excuse me centor Catalina
please look hand pressure he should not
be in the kitchen at all one two three
filters and everything's coming out
wrong this
unbelievable
goodbye bch coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares I'm the boss here we have to
listen to me the chaos goes from bad to
worse Kata is out of control Marcel get
out of the kitchen get out of the
kitchen and Marcelo is out the door
what's wrong with this guy then you're
not going to believe what's hidden
downstairs Chef Ramsay's shocking
discovery that makes everyone's sick I
could not believe my eyes can Chef ramsy
bring these two together and get the
restaurant back back on track do you
think it's time that one of you says
goodbye or will one of them walk out of
the restaurant for good see you later
that's next on Kitchen
Nightmares after a terrible lunch
service Chef Ramsey wants to meet kata's
business partner Marcelo as well as the
chef's responsible for his meal how are
you fine thank you yeah good and this is
Eduardo
Eduardo okay um let me let me just tell
you something lunch was a disaster who
is the head chef I am the head you're
the head chef yes talk about the black
beans was that perfect no the the beans
was not perfect was salty who cooked the
tilapia I cook it it was
raw I could hear a lot of shouting what
is that normal that's all we here every
day what do you mean every day every
single day he aggravates everybody Kat
always pushing me pushing me just say
listen do your thing let me do my thing
but she's in her thing and in my thing
all together checking your performance
you're not my boss I'm not your boss by
your apart you know what happen when you
are a to of be everything got
worse you still live together no we
separated he lives on he has his own
apartment and I live here in the
building upstairs upstairs literally
upstairs oh dear okay uh right now I
need some fresh air I'm going to go for
a walk and I'll be in service tonight
watching everything and try to do a
better job than you did for me lunchtime
okay I'll be back even with CHF fry
there's absolutely no hope for this
restaurant to
[Music]
survive after a miserable lunch Chef
Ramsey wants to see how this feuding
couple handles dinner service guys chff
Ram is here please keep focused and do
everything according don't send
everything out that is not right I think
she use a long lasting battery because
tuck and talk and Tu and
Tuck Catalina the pretty girl own of the
restaurant giving orders to everybody
and don't do nothing she don't do
nothing what's all that [__] on the
Windows there what is all that the blue
botles just it's just for for decoration
decoration decoration that's it water
but what have you colored it with the
toilet bowls toilet bowls I make that
the the blue water and I put it on to
put in the I mean I've heard of
restaurants botling water but is just
for decoration just for decoration for
drink not for human consumption unless
you've eaten
here word has spread of Chef Ramsey's
arrival in Brooklyn Hi how are you and
mojito is busier than usual you guys
have reservation either one of these to
tables enjoy your dinner
guys can I just do the like the grilled
shrimp
[Music]
thank with the first orders in Chef
Ramsey is looking forward to seeing the
head chef in
[Music]
action are you Expediting yes you are
you could open up at least
talk the kitchen stuff we do so much
better without marel stop putting the
tickets that I'm already starting there
here because it's all [__] me up he
doesn't know what the hell he's doing
he's not appetizer it is an appetizer oh
yeah you're right what is that for
that's for
A3 A3 yes no I need it look clearly
Marcelo has no control of his kitchen oh
my God not only is food slowly making
its way to the dining
room the dishes are not exactly being
well received terrible is horrible
really what's wrong with the sh what's
up with the impan going to have a
regular stuff all right I'll be happy to
help them fix that for you okay's
they're undercooked they want them cook
a little bit more oh Marcel please keep
checking that everything that comes che
che we got it we got it we got it Marcel
doesn't exp that he doesn't have
consistency he just like send things out
just to get him out of the way they
ordered the shrimp CIA but the gentleman
says that he really doesn't like it
would you like to order something
instead of that I don't want to go to go
home hungry all right no problem I'm
sorry guys you have this
[Music]
question who made this you you guys
should know better how can you allow
food to come out like that nasty no NY
at all I'm we are doing something you're
going to tell me that is supposed to be
crispy and it was like soggy not it's
supposed to be nicer the bad part of
Kata is that she's not actually Hands-On
she's just adding fire you're trying to
sabotage this she's making the situation
worse you're not doing it right I'm
painting right perfect perfect like
always not perfect
oh dear Mar a beaten man he's soulless
if that's Expediting well he knows when
we set at home Kata well she can
definitely talk but she's not doing
anything talk talk talk talk but nothing
being done kitchen's in chaos and the
ran is [__]
sinking it's it's cold I don't want it
it's I'm done Chef Ramsey has seen
enough of this service customers are
unhappy and there's chaos in the kitchen
so he decides to take a break from the
madness and check out the food storage
look at all this food in here and what
he finds is an outrageous amount of food
for a failing restaurant how much
produce is in this fridge trays and
trays of produce look they put the fresh
one at the front and at the back you've
got the squidgy
one marinated
skirt oh tilapia that is what you call
dry chicken that's more chicken there
must be thousands and thousands of
dollars worth of food here if the cash
flow is in the [__]
this is a big reason why thank you very
much have a good night guys after
observing dinner service Chef Ramsey now
knows that Mojito's problems are not
just confined to a bad relationship I
don't argue for no reason in subpar food
we'll never come here again in fact MOS
is in much worse shape than he
thought right let's start off with
tonight's uh dinner service or shall I
say a
disservice
customers pissed off uh dishes been
returned if each and every one of you
want this [__] restaurant to work you
all have to reach for a standard whether
you're serving food whether you're
cooking food or whether you're sending
food at the end of service I pop
downstairs who does the purchasing in
here who buys the fish the meat and the
vegetables me
mar stay there stay there let me just
show you
something right now I'm Prett nervous
cuz I I don't know what going to happen
just take that out for me please just
bring the whole train out for me I don't
know what's going to happen I don't know
what to expect I'm
scared
oh
man Mojitos is over
$300,000 in debt I am amazed what Chef
Ramsey found in the basement is one of
the reasons
why no oh my God I'm not even want to
look thank
you all
okay I was speechless how can Marcelo
allow something like this to
happen I've never seen such waste in my
entire life You' got enough food down
there to serve a banquet of
5,000 there's seven of these down there
seven I don't know if I going to kill
Eduardo first or I going to kill myself
first this
is rapidly shutting down the
restaurant I've got some work to do and
I got to get out of there guys that
makes me feel sick I'm the owner and
this is my kitchen this is my place I
should be the one taking control of the
situation Chef Ramsey uncovered many
problems at mojito but for this
restaurant to ever work properly he has
to understand the issues between Marcelo
and [__] so he spends the the morning
with both of them okay all I've seen so
far is a bossy angry little princess the
restaurant suffering on the back of both
you constantly hurting each other he
does it to you you do it to him and it's
so sad and it's affecting everybody else
down the line it's embarrassing take me
back 7 years when you got
married we are together all time
everybody said you are the perfect
couple we decide to have a baby so we
started to do f ation process the IVF
and nothing happened I was putting
everything into it MH and I was willing
to sacrifice and to do and go through
the treatment but it was no support from
him like while I was on the treatment
injecting myself he was out paring with
friends I was being left alone that's
when I'm like no not happening you're
not coming home to me at 7:00 in the
morning I'm your wife yeah so that's
when everything started going wrong how
did the marriage break down she go to to
Florida for 1 year and a half in Miami
did she meet somebody else in Miami did
she meet another man in Miami yeah I
took a trip during the trip I decided so
I was going to leave him you're not
making me happy I'm not making you happy
go your way I'll go my way do you think
it's time that one of you says goodbye
to the business and give each other
space I think we'll be very
[Music]
healthy I want C of of this business she
don't have any idea of how run a
business she don't do nothing how
important is the business for you it's
everything for me the person that I was
married to the person doesn't exist
anymore he's
gone and I have to move
on and that's what I'm doing and I take
the loss of my marriage
mhm and I think that's the price that I
have to pay for my business so I'm
taking care of my business because
that's all I have
left
whatever it takes I'll go to the
end until I feel that there's nothing
else that I can
do I've got a plan I just I need to see
you like it was 4 and a half 5 years ago
you know funny confident and no
bickering I'm committed okay thank
you stand strong thank
you
Marcel and I if we don't find a way to
communicate if we don't find a way to
get to an agreement the restaurant is
going to go down the drain but Marcel
really drives me crazy I don't think
it's going to work
[Music]
ever while Kata and Marcelo have both
lost their passion for each other Chef
Ramsey wants to know if they still have
their passion for the food one thing I
haven't seen since I've been here is you
two working together so that's what
exactly what we're going to do
[Music]
now with all these ingredients in front
of you cook me something authentic
something Cuban and do it together oh
gosh are we going to be able to do this
I no arur yes we can be together at the
[Music]
kitchen so okay I'll make the shrimp
with a pineapple sauce okay let me do
the fre sh Marcel wanted to make chicken
but I wanted to do my shrimp so we
starting cooking two dishes instead of
one very quiet in here everything okay
everything good everything's good is
this dish done together we're doing two
dishes [__] hell I want to see you
two Muppets work together one dish oh my
God that's not going to happen Okay okay
okay don't frak to just keep moving okay
one dish two 50/50 oh
unbelievable
okay chicken with potatoes whose idea
was it to do the shrimp whose was it me
mhm simple
flavors I think I did a much better job
than
Marcel I like that nice that's
nice what is that chicken for
presentation it's not as attractive as a
shrimp clearly
[Music]
not blow me away it's mediocre the
shrimp is the dish I'd love to pay for
in a local Cuban Resturant we'll do that
as a special tonight
yes makes me feel wonderful that M dis
has been chosen for those specials by
Chev ransy and honor okay good now do me
one more favor [__] off out together
through the door see if you can just
manage walking out
[Music]
together
you know while Chef Ramsey works on
another special with Chef Eduardo why
let's do something together yes
something special is also happening out
in the dining room Marcelo Kata and
Marcelo are communicating I wanted to
ask you if you want to switch tonight be
in the kitchen you want to be here when
you come out here you stay up front you
just like follow the lead re we got to
talk to CH from see if he allows us to
do that if he allows it I go into the
kitchen the people at the
kitchen going to run out with her
attitude with
her she's a
nightmare coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares I'm the boss here remember
who I am C us on the war path in the
kitchen if I want to scream I can do it
and nothing he's standing there doing
nothing or nobody I'll do it myself
we'll get in her way you have to listen
to me everything is a disaster and the
dining room led by Marcel
is a circus don't bounce around like a
monkey will this soap opera have a happy
ending or will Mojitos go up in Flames
get out the kitchen get out of the
kitchen that's next on Kitchen
Nightmares Chef Ramsey's plan for
tonight's dinner service features his
garlic chicken and cot a shrimp with
mango salsa tonight is going to be a lot
better than we had last night yes yes
but Kata has a plan of her own um CHF
Ramsey we're going to be switching
places oh Marcelo and I I'm going to be
in the kitchen starting he's going to be
from
[Music]
house I mean that that sounds great uh
who came to that decision we both of yes
woo Round of
Applause that's amazing
wow well everybody's happy so I want
fast efficient service hot [__] food
and more importantly you got to show me
that you can handle those small Chang es
expedite host serve cook let's go yeah
[Music]
yeah hey how are you you welcome to
mojito thank
you 10 point I'm definitely really
nervous about tonight's dinner service I
don't think Marcelo does well in the
front of the house okay don't bounce
around like a monkey yeah walk in the
[__] dining room as patrons enter the
restaurant welcome to
you will find the speci over here K
takes the helm in the kitchen while you
work for me I'm your Bo so you're here
and fryer this is your section I can
definitely handle pressure in the back
of the house it needs more chicken than
vegetables and I know I'm going to do a
much better work than Marc how you doing
guys we have a couple of specials
tonight it's a lemon and garlic Garden
chicken uh we also have h two Jumbo
grilled shrimp with a tropical salsa
take one of those you want the Chicken
special thank you so much
here we go guys first order
yes guacamole Che beef and panas and
then we're going to have a gar chicken p
marasco and one ofas one chicken one
beef let me have an order of jumbo
shrimp and one guacamole two Chicken
special thank you team another order of
the jumbo shrimp special well done
tonight's dinner service is off to a
good start good K has control of the
kitchen one chicken thank you so much
and customers are enjoying the specials
really I don't know why but it feels
better tonight better why Catalina is
awesome in the kitchen two wacan chips
one tropical shrimp Marcel is actually
better in the front cuz it's less stress
on him thank you so much so he's better
in the front she's better in the kitchen
yeah I believe so three more chickens in
total yeah you look so good and composed
back here that's how you do itell holler
back baby holler back thank you baby all
doll
this restaurant is still chaotic but
there's a massive significant difference
Kata can handle pressure a thousand
times better than Marcel and the good
news is the specials are flying out
while the new specials are a big hit
with the diners really good the original
menu is striking out have to get
something else just a very strange taste
to it coming up what's wrong you didn't
like the uh strange taste strange taste
yes okay let's go guys pick up I thought
this steak was on strange taste can I
have little hand stead yes down the
window come on wake up keep it
respectful remember who I am don't give
me attitude cuz I don't need to give you
attitude I'm the boss like it or not you
have to listen to me you waiting for
your sides still right
yesing it for wait let me have the
ticket what's the mess for the ticket
I'm feeling a lot of pressure there's
low tickets there's uh food coming out
WR everything is a disaster and Chef
Ramsey is watching us I need a container
for their tickets and Ice buckers say I
need a spike in the kitchen cuz we're
losing [__] tickets for AO sandwich
right my God those sandwiches are not
ready yet almost done almost done almost
done when we get busy Kata loses herself
she becomes very confused we have one
out our tropical shrimp that went out
already everything went out she doesn't
know what really is going on wait wait M
hold on hold on hold on that's
[Music]
chaos
it's an hour and a half into dinner
service and the restaurant is in utter
turmoil what is it for there are lost
orders I need a spike in the kitchen cuz
we're losing tickets unhappy customers
it tastes like fast and Kata is spinning
out of control hold on hold on hold on
Mojitos is on the Rocks once again St
getting cold we cannot have any more
food waiting for one order one order for
one tiet like
this minut later 5 minutes later Marc
get out of the kitchen get get out of
the kitchen she become like a tiger get
out of my kitchen H hell go out out of
the kitchen okay now get out of the
kitchen what what's wrong with this girl
she crazy there perfect thank you that
doesn't leave there yeah yeah the
kitchen is getting behind everything is
getting is not coming out right
everything's going wrong have to like
take control and do something take some
action all right guys this order we have
to make it perfect perfect yeah here we
go yeah okay so you need two Tasco
medium two Garden chickens one pesc
Marino one milanesa breaded is the
chicken
coming1 after a good start a miserable
middle Kata pushes for a strong finish
take that take that
take Kata seems to be doing better get
two chickens yes nice now she's got a
better grip on tickets on Expediting
take that chicken m go got him got him
brilliant well done tonight was so much
better than last night a lot
smoother care good
night after an up and down service Chef
Ramsey knows that for mojitos to reach
its potential that is beautiful K and
Marcelo have to be on the same page okay
first of all tonight was better but let
me tell you we can't just get by on two
specials we need to be consistent so it
was a small step forward now we have to
take a giant leap forward that will be
done tomorrow we're going to relaunch
this
restaurant I'm going to be working on
the menu throughout the whole night but
before I leave you here I'm going to ask
you a very serious question and I spent
a lot of time with both of you and I I I
totally accept that the possibility of a
husband and wife scenario is not on the
cards that is not going to happen but
you both own the place and what I need
to know from both of you is that are you
prepared to put the Grievances your egos
your frustrations your anger aside and
completely focus on your baby and that
is the mahita restaurant cuz if you can
do that you've got a strong possibility
of making this place work if you can't
then we have a big [__]
problem good
[Music]
night have to
us let's Go's go and do it I hope in my
heart are Kata and me can work together
I think we're going to be on track with
the belief that Kata and Marcelo were
committed to working together Chef
Ramsey and his team spend the night
giving Mojitos a much needed
makeover good morning welcome to Mojitos
the new Mojitos yes doesn't it feel
twice as big hello Cuba this looks
amazing
amazing blocking out all that natural
light was crazy look how bright this
place is it look fres open first thing
that's gone missing are the 500 bottles
that was stopping all that natural light
oh that's beautiful take a look at where
your bottles have
gone look no more blue Rings
cleaner it's the new beginning of the
restaurant soy Char what do you think
wow this is amazing this is a huge step
moving forward and this has like Inspire
us and like give everyone this part that
we were missing to keep going and keep
working hard great restaurant yes yes
now you need a proper menu
so menu's been cut in half why we need
speeds
yes we keep it small we keep it fresh
and more importantly we no longer need
to keep 10,000 worth of ingredients
downstairs that's not been turned yes
yes you happy
extremely good
unbelievable when I see crying like a
like a
baby I really feel really happy for
her I'm so happy so so so so so so happy
today is the beginning of a new chapter
inside mjos thank you come here come
here you little
firecracker he this is the best yes this
is the
best with the renovation done and
Marcelo and Kato's relationship on the
menend Chef Ramsey has done away with
the cafeteria style food and in its
place contemporary Cuban Cuisine look at
the difference in the portion size first
baked cot meat balls Entre slow Roose
pork bra short rib authentic and
sumptuous a lot less but visually it's
beautiful from the new menu I find a lot
of exciting new things wow meat balls
wow I'm so excited I'm really looking
forward for
tonight for relaunch night with Chef
Ramsey's blessing Kata and Marcelo
decide to work the front of the house
greeting customers leaving Chef Eduardo
in charge of the kitchen you convinced
you can do it
yeah and Marell 2 seconds uh I've
managed to get a really amazing VIP
guest here this evening he's the
president of the Brooklyn burrow so look
after him yeah thank you we will
everything's on the line tonight Marcel
and I have to come together otherwise
we're going to
fail welcome to mojito how many are you
guys four how love this way guys look
good here used to be a lot are you guys
ready you got Cub okay for the first
time in 5 years Brooklyn only Cuban
restaurant clearly has a buzz in the
dining room awesome thank you gentlemen
so much and as for the
kitchen it's a different
story very quiet here guys huh Eddie two
orders on yeah nothing called out you're
not going to call the orders out to the
team those tickets come in you got to be
in control Big Boy Yes good man y fo
should be out any minute okay pick up
with Chef Eduardo's lack of
communication food is leaving the
kitchen slowly be right back with the
beans and when it does arrive in the
dining
room some customers received dishes they
didn't even order had a Cuban
sandwich
guys if I missing a Cuban I told what
came back this bab that's because they
order a Cuban sandwich not the pork not
the pork unbelievable Look at me now
you've got to call out the [__]
orders cuz he's cooking blind okay yeah
so he needs some form of dire
yeah and don't forget to send Bean out
with every order oh [__] impression full
great atmosphere unfortunately food
started coming back and Eduardo has
[__] shut down not tonight because
this could be a [__]
disaster thought we got six well we did
order six another they're all
chicken we ordered a mix of uh all all
the different flavors and I'm so sorry
they got they got obviously their
information mixed up back there I see
tickets coming back because Eduardo was
completely lost hey guys for is missing
more and pan they have one of each are
we going a little too fast come on
man welcome to moito thank you enjoy the
food and this is the table special for
you okay yes the president of The Bard
is here and the kitchen is a
disaster completely
disast what is this so are taking it
what
table the steak's cold as well the
president of the world is here Edd's not
next for that he's not talking he's not
communicating if Eddie doesn't start to
speak up this kitchen is going to go
down give me a
[Music]
break it's relaunch night and the
president of the Brooklyn burrow has
arrived and the timing couldn't be worse
Eduardo was a mess and shf Ramsey knows
he has to step in turn those States over
2 seconds Me 2 seconds literally 2
seconds come on what's the matter huh
what's the matter I'm [__] all over I
know you're [__] all over the place
but what you're not doing for you for me
for the resturant no one's
talking okay I'm going to put my dis
Wasatch into FR because I need do
something okay I guess okay come on Edie
I got you I got you [__] me talk just do
something but talk come on okay you can
do it come here come here the president
of The Bard is here and the kitchen is
AER right now I have to do something and
I have to do it now here we go here we
go let's go let's expedite this we're
concentrating a pesc
Marino only
Rask okay nice here we go that's the
most important order of the night that's
one guy we cannot afford to piss off
tonight
[Music]
exactly the new and the RO for fish fish
coming out right now excellent Ro I need
another beautiful beautiful guys we need
more plantings can we do we have more
it's coming and five give me five give
me five thank
you thank
you bud Kata and me are working together
well again I going to do this and you do
that let's go with Kata and Marcelo
finally working together as a team all
right the kitchen is back on track this
is three B
three and now the only thing left to
make the night a success is satisfying
the burough president how's everything
here they loved everything yeah baby
yeah [__] Marcel took control the whole
situation he was very put together very
calm very relaxed he really got things
going in that make me gain more respect
for him but it means a lot for us for
you guys to be here I appreciate it
thank you nice to see you best wishes
thank you that's it that's it I think
that the passion is back I'm back I'm
back again thank you thank you so much
bye-bye have a good
night Kata and Marcelo came together
like the team they once were and
Mojito's relaunch was a success right
tonight wasn't perfect but I did see one
thing that that I haven't witnessed at
Mojitos for the first time and that was
teamwork well done what do you think
about the future of this restaurant now
before it was really uncertain we didn't
know if we're going to last a month a
week a day now we have a long-term
future it's up to both of you are you
seriously willing to put your past aside
and commit to your baby I already
start I feel great this night I get the
energy that I had 5 years
ago it feels great to see Marcelo smile
him showing his emotions just s in my
home
do me a
favor tell each other how important it
is you are my partner and I need your
support and I need your commitment so if
you committed to me I'll be 110 120 200
committed to you to make it work into
the restaurant I I need
you to
continue you are the the half of that
I'm going to do everything that it takes
to make it work you guys work well
together tonight prove that I feel in in
in my heart that I get catak I get my
partner back don't stop You' be mad to
come
[Music]
on thank you good to see you guys great
team what a night when I first arrived I
honestly didn't think it was possible
that Kata and Marcelo could actually
work together but tonight they proved
proed me wrong now I'm wondering if the
restaurant that actually ruined the
marriage could now be the restaurant
that saves the marriage Fu me only time
will tell you live in Hope get me a
strong
mojito after Gordon's departure Marcelo
and Kata were determined to follow his
advice we need to work as a team we need
to be able to pay all this thanks to
Gordon's smaller menu Marcelo buys less
produce saving nearly $10,000 a month
and he and Kata wasted no time promoting
the new Mojitos we want to invite
everyone to come and shake it up I'm
they got the word out to the community
by using the popular Brooklyn Flea
Market winning rave reviews really good
good yeah and I can taste the spices in
there it's very rich more importantly
Marcelo and K are fighting less and
laughing
[Music]
more